the diver ceo live my live show my live
reincarnation of this podcast is coming
on tour and it's coming to a city near
you there's a link in the description
below put your email address in and i
will email you when tickets go on sale
can't wait to see
[Music]
i know what i've done has been culture
changing and i'm super proud of that
all hell would kick loose if that
happened today i was poisoned by my
nanny i've had a bullet through the post
it was so important to me not to feel
like a victim you know anybody that's
listening will not know the crusade that
i've been on i don't really know what to
say honestly i feel speechless yeah
gosh it is hard i was diagnosed with
breast cancer when i spoke to the
consultant he said
[Music]
jacqueline gold
she is one of the most successful
business women in europe she's also one
of the wealthiest women in the uk
and
she's certainly one of the most
inspiring people i have ever
ever met just remarkable
but her road to success is one of the
most devastatingly
misfortunate
tragic heartbreaking roads i think we've
ever heard travelled on this podcast
imagine me speechless
this podcast made me speechless not once
not twice but over and over again
she is and has been the ceo of anne
summers for decades
a company that if you don't know is
known for popularizing sex toys
dismantling the unhealthy archaic
stigmas around sex and starting a
crusade to make sex i'm a widely
accepted part of all of our lives
but her story twists and it turns the
lessons the courage the resilience the
heartbreak the pain
this should be a movie you just couldn't
make it up
jacqueline
thank you for your honesty thank you for
your courage and thank you for the
inspiration i know that it will stay
with me for a lifetime
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the dire ceo
i hope nobody's listening
but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
i really hate when um podcasts are quite
predictable however i've noticed that in
my podcast i've continued to start in a
very similar place
and it's i can't get away from it and
the place that i always tend to start is
about the person that sat in front of me
early years
and how those early years have shaped
them and as i was reading about your
story i actually read that you'd said
that i read that you'd said your early
adversity
heavily shaped who you are today and who
you became and influenced the career
journey you took so
i have to start there and i feel like i
always start there but can you tell me
about that early adversity that you're
talking about
yes i can um
i had a really
unconventional
and challenging
childhood
my parents
split up when i was 12. my sister was a
lot younger than me she was seven years
younger than me so it didn't impact her
in the same way as it impacted me
um i found it
it was quite traumatic i
actually stayed down a year at school
because of the impact it had on me
and at the same time my mother moved in
with her boyfriend
um
who sexually abused me between the age
of 12 and 15.
you know and that combined with a mother
who was overprotective
you know wouldn't let
me or my sister just do anything and
play in the normal way
you know we weren't allowed to go to
sleepovers or parties or anything like
that
but then
when it came to this abuse which i
believe she knew about
um
you know we were left in the most
vulnerable situations
um
you know she was quite a complicated
woman
and you know we were in a
a pretty tough situation so for me
later in life in fact i say later in
life i probably was
about 15
you know
finding financial independence was
really important to me because that was
my escape
it's hard to it's hard to imagine a
parent
knowing about
about that especially as you say one
that was so
risk adverse
was so keen to keep you in the house to
not let you outside because you might
fall into a dangerous situation but
would
turn a blind eye tonight
i mean you know i've tried to
rationalize this myself numerous times
because she was
she was quite ill in her later years so
i didn't challenge her i just felt she
was and even in her earlier years i just
felt
i always felt she was very vulnerable
herself um
you know just
she
she once said to me if i could live in
the middle of a field
with no one around me i'd be happy
so she herself
wanted to be protected
in one sense you know she she wouldn't
even let my sister and i play in the
front garden in case we were kidnapped i
mean it was
you know totally irrational
and yet
stayed with a man
you know i remember overhearing her on a
in a phone conversation with her sister
after he'd returned after a year's break
and i remember hearing her say yes i
know he's a bastard but
you know i i don't want to be on my my
own it was just a toxic you know a toxic
relationship a toxic environment
um
and i and
you know i i have forgiven her
um
but i feel very sad for for her and
and the life that she lived
did she ever admit to knowing
that her partner was abusing you no
did you ever ask her
i didn't ask her
but there were many occasions when i
called out for help
and a couple of occasions that she
either witnessed or
overheard me telling someone you know i
was told off for telling lies
even my aunt has later told me that she
saw
something going on she told my mum about
it who
played it down so there were lots of
situations where it was clear to me that
she would have known
do you know much about her upbringing
and what might and what um
the early sort of experiences that
shaped her
no i mean i i think that i mean my
grandmother was lovely
um my grandfather was an authoritarian
um you know
her sister grew up
you know
perfectly well but she
she was very was was very insecure
beautiful woman
you know very elegant but
you're just scared of life
and your younger sister you've got a
younger sister i have
yeah she's uh
seven years younger than me
fantastic business woman
great people person and somebody who
really
you know
i admire her so much vanessa we have a
great relationship and she's funny and
engaging and
yeah and she's my best friend
you grew up in the same household with
her
but you turned out to be very different
people and you're only a couple of years
apart because you talked there about at
the very start about how just being a
couple of years apart in those early
years experiences even if you're in the
same household can create two completely
different people
because they both experience very very
different things because of age
and i i really resonated with that
because um like even in my in my
childhood my family became on the verge
of bankruptcy when i was
um old enough to know what was going on
but
my older brothers and sisters kind and
also when i was probably most
influential so sort of easily influenced
like adversity showed up in my childhood
when i was
when i was at like the ripest of ages um
and so i'm very very different from my
brothers and sisters and i kind of
felt that from what you said there the
difference between you and vanessa
was just a couple of years off but um
you experienced very different things
in those early years
yes
i think vanessa was also a bit more
outspoken than me and i think that
you know as a child maybe it was because
of the way my mother was and the fact
that you know for my first um
seven years of life i was an only child
and
uh
i don't know but i i was very
i was very shy and i remember my mother
used to if we went on a beach holiday
she used to draw a circle in the sand
put me in the middle and i wasn't
allowed outside that circle
um so i i never really had opportunities
to make friends with other children and
engage with
adults i was i always felt quite lonely
bizarrely whereas
i think the second child always
you know has it easier in my opinion um
as i keep reminding my sister
and so you know she just was that much
more confident more much more outspoken
so
i don't think she was ever you know
likely to be a
a target
i'm not saying she wasn't but
because we we haven't spoken about it
but
i think she's less likely to have been a
target of of abuse than i was
um
you've never spoken about it well we
have spoken about it but i don't think
she wants to
she just doesn't want to talk about her
experience
which is which is you know i respect
that and you know and
everybody deals with
adversity in different ways
um
and you know no matter how successful
somebody is or
privileged they may be
you know it doesn't change
you know the
the challenges that we might experience
along the way
and everybody deals with them in
different ways and for me
it was so important to me not to feel
like a victim i didn't want to feel like
a victim i hate the word
and that's not to say
you know that
other people handle it wrong it's just
for me
i just wanted to
i suppose
gain something from that bad experience
you know whether it be proof that i can
you know and actually i've experienced
adversity throughout my life i've i've
been quite unfortunate you know in that
way um
you know i lost my son when he was six
years old
i was poisoned by my nanny i've had a
bullet through the post so i've had a
number of challenges
subsequently to
the childhood experience but
certainly just going back to that the
childhood experience
did i believe shape who i am today i
think it drove me to want to go out and
work hard
uh have that financial independence you
know i was
always curious always talking to people
always looking for
inspiration i guess
and so much of just thinking about that
as well so much of your work now because
i've been through your story multiple
times and looked at the way that you've
made your decisions and so much of it is
is centered on that idea of like
empowerment and giving you know
empowering people to be free from
whatever
their prisoner might be and sometimes
prisoner is society sometimes it's
social narratives whatever else but um
i've really i deeply respect that about
you
because i read there was a day in your
story where you
confronted your abuser and that ended up
being a really pivotal moment
could you tell me about that
yeah
um
gosh it is hard yeah
going back and remembering those
periods in time that you you just want
to
park away but
i was 15.
i'd be trying to plan how i was going to
do this for some time
but obviously you lack the courage
you know
i was a very young
15 year old as well
um
and
i didn't want to
you know generate anger i mean he was
the rows that my mother used to have the
coercive control that i witnessed
made me want to make this as
you know easy as possible
so
in my childish way i decided to
tell him it wasn't fair on mum
so
it was
i was trying to i mean
is this something we do as
as girls i think girls are brought up to
be helpful and to please people please
and
this is you know i'm sure we're coming
on to empowerment but that was
you know that was the problem i was
brought up to be well behaved and to be
a people pleaser and take john up a cup
of tea and you know he likes you and
this all this type of stay inside your
circle
yeah
um
[Music]
so for me the best way to handle this
was to
help him not lose face or not feel bad
or
so
and he he just
he didn't really say anything he just
shrugged
um
and that was it was as easy as that and
it never happened again
but i didn't
when i look back or if i was talking to
my
you know young self now
i didn't realize
you know that i could stand up to him
and that i
was perhaps more powerful than i
realized
i'm disappointed as an adult that i felt
i had to approach it in the way i did
but then i forget that that you know i
am an adult
i was a child then
and
i was incredibly brave
you know i could have done nothing
um and i did i was able to bring it to
an end
um
and
you know whilst it's very difficult to
forgive somebody that has put you
through that much pain and
trauma in your life
um as a person i have to take positives
from anything negative that happens to
me
and everything that i've been through
that for me is how i survive that's for
me how i
better my life how i go on to better
things and
you know
i turned my focus to work and to
ambition and
being curious and learning different
things and then just seeing this
opportunity
which actually
turned out to be
a great opportunity to empower women
you know a lot of people are well
because you went through that abuse
why would you go into something like
this
but
there was an opportunity there and
you know
fast forward
i mean i'm 61 now i was 21 when i
started so fast forward 40 years 25.
you say all the right things whatever
you do
you're 61.
[ __ ] me
mental that's crazy
so
i know what i've done has been culture
changing
and i'm super proud of that i really am
and you know i've
you know anybody that's listening that
is
25 will not know the crusade that i've
been on
for the last 40 years
i mean it's
you just wouldn't believe that you you
know what you couldn't do and what you
what you couldn't do then what you can
can do now
and the changes and attitudes of
you know the generations of today
compared to the generations then i
really want to talk about that because i
know you've had some really tumultuous
experiences going on that crusade and i
love i love talking about
shifting perceptions and also we've seen
in our lifetime how quickly a lot of
perceptions have shifted around like
you know equality and sexuality and
gender and um the crusade that you you
know
led i think is is has been a really
important one and probably more
important than a lot of people realize
um i wanted to pick up on one thing you
said about you being shy
you know the what you've gone on to do
in your career and life and the crusade
you've led is not one that would you
know one would think would be led by a
shy person
the person that i've met today doesn't
seem to be a shy person necessarily to
me seems to be one of conviction and
confidence and belief in hindsight how
did you go from being that shy person
that was kind of
coddled
um at an early age by a mother that was
risk adverse
drew a circle around you in the sand
didn't let you off the front garden
to being the person you are today what
is it that check that what is it that
does that to somebody
um well i think there's a few things
around this because um
i don't think this is exclusive to me i
think a lot of women especially
uh
experience this i think well first of
all i
i might be wrong but i don't think we're
born shy i think it's our situational
environment that creates that and
secondly you can be shy but still have
fire in your belly which is what i had
you know i had that ambition and that
burning desire
and
when you have that passion
you have to release it you can't keep it
inside just because you're shy and um
i think there were many things that i
did you know i remember
in my very early 20s holding
a conference my first conference for my
army of of um
sales ambassadors which i had about 500
in my first year franz summers veranda
summers yes
and i held this conference at the
grand hotel in
brighton
and i thought it was a great idea when i
planned it because the whole idea is to
engage with your teams and tell them
about what you're doing and what your
mission is and get everybody involved
and on the journey
and it was sort of you know
a few hours before i was going on stage
i was thinking oh my god what am i doing
because this was like
horror to me i had no experience and
i was you know absolutely terrified
but
if you're talking about something that
you are passionate about
i think it changes it it's not the same
as doing your best man speech or
you know getting up for
school and doing your first speech when
you're talking about something that you
really care about
and that you live and breathe
once you get out there and you've got
that first sentence out the way
i do think it changes you yeah and you
know
that's what it did for me so
i
i am a great believer that courage comes
first and i've always had a lot of
courage
and i think if you have the courage
eventually the confidence will come
yeah so yeah from what you've said there
it's like the courage is creating is
forcing you to create evidence for
yourself yeah it's forcing you to step
outside your comfort zone
and then we all know anyone that's
successful knows that when you do
great things happen yeah and your
comfort zone then expands becomes a bit
bigger and then you step on other than
exactly
interesting um so you said they're about
work and you've always had that drive
when i was reading through a story again
i i heard about
one of the things your mum did allow you
to do was to work
um
and
so i was i was thinking about the the
relationship work you then had in your
life from a very early
um
from a very early stage if if work was
the place that you were allowed to go to
to leave the home
then
was it was it an escape from home was it
like a
the place of freedom in your life
it was so freedom i mean
well first of all i can't tell you the
countless times i asked her if i could
go to a sleepover or a
you know party or just things that
normal kids do
and it was always no um
and there was another
sort of form of abuse was this they had
her and her husband had this uh her new
husband
had this task mask
task master approach to everything they
did and
it was you know there was no end to it
you it's never like you could ever
finish the tasks
and they were
like digging the garden
um they weren't like cleaning the
kitchen they were like digging the
garden bringing logs up you know it was
very
it was manual labor for my sister as
well
and it was like these jobs will never
get done so we'll never be able to go
out a bit like cinderella as i'm telling
the story it sounds a bit like that
um
but she seemed to accept things that
were traditional
so going to work was something
or getting a saturday job is something
that people do
so that was okay
so i couldn't get a bus into bromley
to meet up with friends but i could
get a bus into western to go and
work at the spinning wheel
as a waitress
so did you look forward to that ah
absolutely
and of course there weren't the rules
then you know i was working
at 14 years old i worked in a bar at
biggin hill airfield i did waitressing i
worked in a hairdressing salon
so
um
yeah that was a release
did you try and work all the time
more hours over time and actually it
compromised my schooling because i
i didn't really invest in my schooling i
just wanted to work so i didn't go to
college or university or
anything that i expect my daughter will
probably do now
was there um
and i would i do want to
to talk about some of these other points
around empowerment but was there
any physical and i don't think people
think about this enough but one of the
things i've i've got we're increasingly
fascinated by was the connection between
like psychological trauma and physical
impacts so the on our physical health
and how the two are somewhat interlinked
and was there any sort of physical
symptoms or consequences of that
psychological trauma that
reared their head
so interesting you say that because i
have
a stalker um and his mother many years
ago many years ago
and
the impact was tinnitus i had tinnitus
yeah
and all through there because they they
caught them it was went to trial they
were
um found guilty
i mean it was it's another i mean it's a
crazy story it's a crazy story
can you describe so tinnitus is when you
get the ringing in the ears but actually
i just had this marching it was a
constant marching and it doesn't stop so
when you go to bed you've got you know i
had it oh did you so i know
very few people will know what tinnitus
is like unless you've had it because it
sounds trivial
if i say to you oh it's just like a
ringing in the ears or whatever people
go that's fine like i've been to a gig
before my ears have run yeah but you get
like day two into it and i so i got
tinnitus for
right so i go on google what's this
ringing in my ears and why wouldn't it
stop and that must have been about
six years ago seven years ago
and then you get to day three and you're
losing your mind and i'm on these forums
and people are like people commit
suicide because of because of it
and i i kind of understood why yeah it
was like a form of torture
sleep you wake up it's constant you're
eating lunch your ears are ringing
and there's no end to it there's nothing
you can do to stop it so fortunately you
know
talking about my experience with it one
day i don't really know what happened
but your sinuses are connected to ears
that's when i came to land when i had
tinnitus tinnitus
and i think it must have been because my
sinuses were blocked because on day nine
of my ears ringing it just
stopped
and some people live with it for life
yeah i mean i was very fortunate i think
i had it for about three months and then
it stopped
so i was very lucky i mean some people
have to live it live with it
um but mine was definitely brought on by
that awful experience
and obviously the abuse i i i did i mean
i had
a severe sorry to be graphic but severe
constipation
that um
i look back and i think was
you know brought on by my own
trying to be in control behavior
just remembered as you said that i
remember going to the doctors about it
and blurting out to the doctor
what was going on at home
and the doctor and i said and i'm really
worried because i've got a younger
sister
and the doctor said to me um
okay do you want me to get social
services involved oh no no no because
you know as a child you think
you're going to be in trouble you think
you're going to be taken away from your
mum
and she's ok
i mean
i mean all hell would kick loose if that
happened today
i don't really know what to say honestly
i feel speechless
because you just can't imagine an adult
hearing that these days and
and posing the question to you about
next steps
just think that just seems unthinkable
perceptions have changed a lot haven't
they around sexual abuse and um
and and also
victim blaming
which i think was was a was a really
destructive habit that society had which
fueled the problem
not having a safe environment to to
speak
thinking that you'd be blamed or you
know
absolutely i think there's still our
challenges
i don't think this is a problem that's
gone away just because we're all more
vocal
and i did a a a project recently and
just going off piece for a moment i was
quite surprised about consent
and
i i did a workshop on consent and
i think there's a lot that we don't know
we don't realize
and i did a
piece around
talking to university students and
you know some
girls go to university expecting to be
assaulted so i do still think there is a
lot
a lot more education that's needed
and maybe that's because i'm the mum of
a 12 year old daughter so things like
that
sort of resonate with me more
i've got to be honest um i completely
agree and i think as a man
um
there is a ton of education that we need
to understand this topic um from
the other side of the spectrum as well
because
a lot of my friends
find themselves in a place my male
friends where they are like
naive
and they know they're naive to what
consent means
i i really agree with you i really agree
with that and i think that i just think
there should be more emphasis in schools
we should be talking about consent more
i interestingly when i did this project
i met a trans man
and
he was telling me that when he was a
woman
he experienced certain
attention unwanted attention
and obviously saw it from a female point
of view
and then
when he transitioned to a man
he was just
blown away by some of the things that he
was hearing
from a man's point of view so um
yeah that that was quite uh enlightening
and interesting those are the
conversations we need to be having for
sure
for sure
you um you said that you talked earlier
on about how you know hard times shape
you and i you know
it's clear that from everything you've
said that resilience is one of your
superpowers
i've i've actually heard i've heard that
written a few times when people talk
about you what does that mean to you
resilience
think that's true i i think i am a
resilient person i think um
for me
the battle is won before the war has
even started
so
for example
i was diagnosed in
2016 with breast cancer i remember my
husband and my sister
when they were first told the news i
could tell they'd been crying
and i'm saying come on guys you know i
need your support here we you know
we need to put strategy together we've
got to put a plan together because
that is how
that's my mindset my mindset has always
been that way there's got to be a
solution to this you know there's got to
be something better that can come from
this
it was a brutal journey
um there is no doubt about that um
but i remember saying things to myself
like when i have my next scan
the cancer is going to be gone
and
when i had my next scan in the january
it had gone
or
it wasn't on the scan i then had
an operation in the
in the july i think it was uh a
lumpectomy
and i was told i was all clear
and that there was a
one 0.1 percent chance it would come
back because i'd had such a good
response to treatment
unfortunately i was in that 0.1
and it did
return a couple of years later
and i had a mastectomy
and
when i
spoke to the consultant he said
it's not curable but it is treatable
uh because it's now gone from stage two
to stage four which was you know
which was devastating to hear and of
course i
i immediately said to him well um
you know
what are the chances of it being cured i
know you're saying it it's not curable
but we've all heard of people oh yes but
you know that's not not point
and my attitude is well if anyone's
going to be that 0.1 is going to be me
because
i have to think like that that's what
helps
drive me forward and
get me out of these situations if i
could have been that 0.1
where it went wrong i can be that 0.1
where it goes
brilliant
and actually i'm right now
in what they call excellent remission
so
you know i'm still got my i still have
ambitions for more
but i am feeling blessed at where i am
and i think that has a lot to do with
with my outlook on life and that's the
learning you know when
nobody wants to wish this you know
serious illnesses or life-threatening
illnesses on ourselves but
for me i have to find the opportunity in
that
where's where's the good thing where's
the opportunity well it has made me live
a much healthier life
you know i do appreciate things so much
more you know i am a different person i
put you know my priorities have changed
i love the female empowerment side of
what i do and i want to invest more time
in that i think this is far more
important to me and i think
finding your passion is so
so vital whether you are going through
health issues or not in everything that
you do
that bias towards optimism that you
describe like
you know it sounds like you could be
thrown in any sort of situation and
you'd be looking at the as you say like
the 0.1
chance of
a positive outcome
that's a really really remarkable thing
right and you've you know you've been
the ceo of a tremendous company you'll
you'll be able to look at your
organization and see those people in
your organization that have that same
bias to optimism when all goes wrong
pandemics show up out of nowhere
they have that bias towards optimism
which is we can
and you know like it doesn't even matter
if we can't because all we can focus on
is we can that's the only choice we have
but you've also probably seen the
negative the other side of that right
and um i guess my question to you is
like
from what you've seen in your
organization and you know even in your
life how important is that
and how costly is the antithesis of that
oh gosh there's a few answers to that
first of all in my personal life the
first thing that comes to mind is my
daughter so when she was in junior
school
every morning without fail
as she left i my husband would take her
to school and i would say i can and she
would shout back i know i can
so we did that every morning and i
didn't want her to grow up having the
that feeling of
lacking in confidence and
being so painfully shy i just wanted to
empower her as much as i possibly can
so it's just that's just a little thing
i used to do
i think um
[Music]
you know the pandemic is a really good
example i mean i remember i mean at our
peak we had 146 stores
you know over the years obviously more
people are going online we've
reduced our our store portfolio
and
then of course the pandemic
anyone having leases had to
uh
negotiate with their landlords and you
know we had
to suddenly be told that all of your
stores i had to be closed i mean i never
i can never forget that moment
it was heartbreaking actually because it
was like my baby you know to suddenly be
told that was incredible
and
then of course you you're thinking
how am i gonna tell my teams we value
our people so much and
this was how we're going to
talk them through what's you know the
plan
because we had to make difficult
decisions we had to let people go
but
bringing those people on that really
difficult journey was so important
talking to them regularly
reassuring them
telling them what our plans were how we
were going to get through this
um
was
it was incredible actually in a
yes we all worked really hard everybody
worked so hard
but they achieved things i never thought
we as a business could achieve i mean
our sales ambassadors you know
went from 4 000 to 20 000 in three
months
um
because we were doing a fantastic job um
i mean you may say differently but i
think we were doing a fantastic job on
social engaging with our customers and
you know keeping the conversations going
and being relevant in what was going on
and
you won't be surprised that we
completely sold out of penis pasta penis
sorry one second
[Music]
take a add break there for peanut though
penis pasta of course okay all the
supermarkets sold out of pasta and we
were pushing
pasta and toilet rolls we were pushing
our penis pasta which is pasta shaped
like penis
okay we were doing and still are doing
some amazing things
it was a very creative time hmm
very innovative forced innovation very
creative and innovative
quick one on this podcast i've spent a
lot of time talking about how huel has
changed my life especially someone that
lives a very fast-paced lifestyle that
wants to also be healthy and not you
know reach for convenient food having a
nutritionally complete um partner in my
life like huell has led me to being in
the best shape of my life but also has
given me high energy has made me feel
good has helped my mental health however
this week i wanted to do something
different because every week i bang on
about the impact it's had on me i
received a dm from somebody this week um
from a young man who picked up um some
huel a couple of months ago after
listening to the podcast which makes me
feel amazing um and they described to me
how having fueled and having a
convenient
alternative to the junk food they were
eating has had a tremendous quote
tremendous impact on every area of their
lives that they would never have
foreseen before
um and this person has continued to send
me videos and sometimes pictures of them
on their heel journey and their
transformation and for me that is why
it's a pleasure to have huel as a
sponsor a company and a brand and a
product that i genuinely believe can
help people change their lives and start
getting nutritionally complete in their
dietary choices
you started working at summers when you
were 19.
i did yes how did that happen
so i was working at royal dalton i had
no
i had no business experience i had
retail experience but
it wasn't
you know roald dawn is a fantastic brand
but it was too quiet
and i wanted a much buzzier environment
they offered me management but i you
know it wasn't really what i wanted to
do so
i was creative as well
so i wanted i guess there was that
creativity
um
and i
i worked at ann summers which was my
father's business at the time
and they were he had sex shops and
um a mail order business
which was like literally tearing a
coupon out of a magazine and posting off
what you wanted
i was only working there as for work
experience and
i was invited to
a tupperware well it wasn't tupperware
it was pippa d but it was sort of like
tupperware style party
and it was closed
and it was in a council
flat in southeast london in thames mead
and i remember
driving there in my mustard colored mini
um i was just you know just these two
women invited me they knew what i did
and i was just a guest
um and they were showing around the
clothes and and then somebody got
i do remember actually having to draw a
picture of my husband's meat and tooth
edge on a piece of paper on top of my
head
that and i was
sort of thinking this is not how i
imagined my career starting
but it's uh it's an interesting story
and it was women at the party sort of
knew i worked at ann summers and said
look why don't you do ann summers
parties we want to
we'd love to be able to spice up our sex
lives but we're we're too embarrassed to
go into a sex shop
and i thought
actually this is quite a good idea
so i got some of the toys and lingerie
from the from
our tottenham court road store we had at
the time
um i held a few parties myself
and uh and i remember
guests at the party sort of passing the
product round like this because
obviously it was switched on
and they were sort of excited
um
curious but incredibly nervous at the
same time which now of course they just
want to know what sizes they come in
what speeds they are it's completely
different
but
they were having fun they were enjoying
themselves that they were talking about
their relationships you know they were
just being open and relaxed and candid
and
i just thought this
this is something completely different
i've never seen anything like this you
don't
even
women's magazines aren't this candid
it was that point i thought if this if i
go forward with this it's going to be
for women only
you know you're just not going to get
that same atmosphere
with with men and also a mixed um group
i just thought
women would feel uncomfortable
uh there'd be other
partners husbands there showing personal
product this isn't this isn't going to
work and i think that was actually one
of the best decisions i made so
of course today it's sort of like a
a female institution
but
we had at that time there was i think 10
of women going in the stores
and i remember
taking this idea to the board
walking down this sort of what felt like
this long corridor into this room full
of all men
all middle-aged all in grey suits
um
and telling them about this party i'd
been to and these parties that i'd held
and you know we we need to do something
different
we should do and summer's parties
i had no business experience by the way
just all from the heart and
i remember one businessman
at the meeting ron coleman he's dead now
so i can talk about it
he stood up and he threw his pen down on
the table and said well this isn't going
to work is it women aren't even
interested in sex
so i instantly thought well actually
this has got a lot more to do about your
sex life than it has about my idea wow
um and you know luckily they agreed to
it to invest in some advertising
so um
i was advertising in the
evening standard
once a week and i wasn't allowed to put
erotic parties i had to put exotic and i
couldn't say ladies only
because of all the rules
but i used to hold like a seminar once a
week at strand palace hotel
and i'd go up there
meet with people that had seen the
advert probably about 25 people in the
room talk to them about my idea
obviously
the men i had to ask
leave some would actually get up and
leave themselves they
you know it was nothing had been done
like this before and i remember i still
remember having those conversations and
i remember remember one
couple it's two women wanted to do the
parties together bored housewives living
in chelsea
not the demographic people would
necessarily expect
and then all of a sudden people were
popping up
groups of people were popping up in
different areas so i recruited the two
girls in chelsea i recruited the eight
women at the
party in thames mead then what i would
do is i would advertise in those area
areas concentrate the advertising in
those areas and it really was
self-propagating then later when we
decided to
right we're ready now to open stores
reopen stores with a through a female
lens
it was like a an induction into the
brand so
um and it still is i think to a degree
it's incredible and something you said
at the start there about being naive in
business i thought was really compelling
because
so much innovation seems to come from
being naive
yeah i agree i had no experience but it
that no experience forced me to rely on
feedback from my customers
you know something we don't always do
enough of
um
because i had no choice and what i saw
as a disadvantage actually turned out to
be
you know one of
my and
the brand's main benefits because
that's
in our dna now that's what we do
it's really interesting i've never heard
a phrase like that that you were
because you didn't have experience or a
ton of knowledge you were learning from
feedback as opposed to like convention
convention doesn't create new things
it's just more of the same yeah and you
know as a woman in business i was only
21
i was
quietly spoken not how people would
expect a business person to be
alone if you like in the sex industry as
it was then i don't sort of think of it
that way now
there's so much negativity so from
business people i would have comments
um i remember one guy i owned a chain of
estate agents saying to me
this isn't going to work it's just a fad
give it two years
you know and i think
people were so used to
doing things how they'd always done them
and we know that don't we when we and
i'm moving on a few years and if it's
okay to go off-piste again because
you know when you think of
heritage brands like
wal-was you know doing things the way
they'd always done things that's why i
say the pandemic there were positives
because it it forced those companies
that have done well
to do things differently
you talked about the phase in your
business where you started opening these
stores
um
in that era you know if someone was to
open a
a shop that was perceived as being just
a sex shop
in my neck of the woods
you know when there was a huge amount of
stigma towards it
i can't imagine people being so happy
about that
it wasn't the people it wasn't if you
weren't if we wanted to go into i mean
i'll give you an example of
loads of examples but you know bromley
um
we really wanted a presence in in
bromley um glade center
and i actually remember you know i was i
went with the landlords and the
um
the center and you know and they were
going right well you know we could do it
we could do it if if we change the if
you could change the name from ann
summers
and there was
a a brand bias
there were many
you know center management that would
say over our dead body and
someone
did someone send you a bullet in the
post yes
what the [ __ ]
why did they send you what uh
god
i wanted to open a store in dublin
the sales per um per head parties were
higher than they were in the uk
so i knew
that
um
you know there were there was an
appetite
and we found this site in o'connell
street which admittedly was
a bit of a controversial location
because it was right opposite the gpo
building
um
and
so you know it's where there were
you know there was violence and clashes
and the dublin corporation which is the
equivalent of our council in fact they
might be called council now
um
were ema not emailing me sending me
letters
you know putting me under pressure not
to go ahead
saying that they had another location
backstreet but i didn't want to be in
the back street
i wanted to be accessible
so they um
in fact it was me i invited them over to
the uk i just wanted them to see our
stores
to see that we weren't trying to shock
people that we you know we were trying
to empower people we were trying to make
it comfortable for women empower women
in the bedroom
but
despite showing them around and
they they
in the after so then during the morning
they were shown round by my retail
director in the afternoon i invited them
to a board meeting
and their names were kieran and alan
kieran couldn't look at me
he sat he sat there without any eye
contact at all
alan sat right next to me right here
telling him every you know they were
really good cop bad cop he's trying to
tell me about his sex life and
i said to them look you know
it's very clear you have your own agenda
you're not going to change your mind
there's no not much pointness carrying
on here
and alan said to me his parting words
were
well i hope you'll understand that we
cannot be held responsible for what
might happen to you
which was a very chilling thing to say
and there was loads of uh
negative media because there was all
this big
hoo-ha about ann summers um going to
o'connell street
and
i'd never done any media before and i
was uh invited
on the late late show which has sort of
got a bit of a cult following yeah
and um
i was you know really nervous about
going on the show but the
producer took me out to dinner and said
it's going to be great you know it's
going to be fine you you know gave me
lots of reassurance
so when i got there uh and i was sat in
the green room
michael crawford was on before me
and uh for those that don't know he was
a
a legend iconic um
comedian he i could hear him on stage
you know he was a comedian so he was
telling jokes and the audience were
laughing and i'm thinking oh my god
what's it going to be like when i go on
you know
so i went on
and i sat on the stage
the presenter had a desk i've sat i was
like at the headmistress his office i'm
telling you i sat there and all the
audience were
uh you know it's a live audience sort of
tear-shaped
he didn't interrupt introduction and
then he then said right we'll get
alan
uh to speak first and i'm like gosh they
never told me about this that allen's
going to be on the show
alan from council from the council
stood up at the front of the stage
and then starts you know beating his
chest telling everyone why there
shouldn't be an summer store in dublin
and then of course it was my turn and i
i just told the story pretty much how i
told you about the sales of the parties
first of all one woman at the very back
at the highest level stood up
and she's pointing down at alan like
this
don't you dare tell us where we can and
can't shop
and it was fabulous because once one
person did it others did it
and despite us being served a writ on
the first day of opening
um
the dublin store is now in our top three
performing stores
and it's also on the tourist bus route
which you know because of that story
which
i think you know for me is great served
a writ a writ yeah so we were taken to
court
we won the court case we got damages
uh because they tried to stop us from
opening
and someone sent you a bullet in the
post after the show oh sorry yes the
bullet in the post that arrived
anonymously obviously a week before
i was due to fly out to dublin
and how did that feel
um
very frightening
but
i just felt
i've had to deal with a lot of
challenges within the business a lot of
preconceived ideas to me
i felt like i was being bullied and it
was actually before
before bullying was even a thing
but that's how i felt and i felt so
strongly about what i wanted to do
that
nothing was going to stop me and i
actually
i did get a
somebody a security person to meet me at
the airport and
you know that was
but that was about it that's what i did
you became ceo of ann summers in what
year was that do you remember i don't
but i was
in my 20s still i think really
becoming a ceo in your 20s is
not easy
especially if you're going to be
completely honest especially if you're a
woman especially in that time in that
era when there is so much discrimination
um
tell me about because i also became a
ceo in my 20s
tell me about the discrimination that
a woman ceo
in that era experiences that i would not
know about
well there's two
as always there's two answers to this
question if that's okay
the first one is about being
[Music]
there were very few business women so
about being a woman in business
you know that you'd meet somebody
at a meeting and they would assume that
your colleague
if they were a man
they would start talking to them so
there was that assumption and i think
there is a possibility that still goes
on now
and actually i as you can tell i'm quite
i'm only five foot one
i looked younger than i was at 21.
and well you need 25 now so
that's unbelievable so i was only two
then and
my managing director
was very tall
although she was a woman she was very
tall
so there is this bias that if you're if
you're short and female that you can't
possibly be running the business but
then i i still have that now so
a few years ago i was speaking i was
doing the keynote speak at the retail
live
show
and i was i remembered i was
interviewing baroness neville rolfe on
stage um about her role in in business
and
some of the challenges that we were
experiencing that the industry was
experiencing and i was just walking the
boards basically getting myself
comfortable
some guy came over and he said i've
still got i've still not got my slides
i'm not looking at him he said i'm not
in half an hour and i've still not got
my i said
i'm i'm speaking oh
and then he just walks off and says
that's oh
[ __ ] you know and and um
another example i've got to tell you
this one i jump on the train at the last
minute with the first glass ticket i've
been there
have you i know exactly you know what
i'm gonna say yeah i'm at london bridge
all the city boys are sitting in there
the train is full
and i just i just come down for
sheffield and just managed to get my
um
connection i was dressed casual
and i said to this guy could could you
move over could you just move over
please so i can sit there he said have
you got a first class ticket yeah
and i looked at him and i said
you're kidding me aren't you
you said no if you got a first-class
ticket i said i'm not answering that and
so he reluctantly moved over and i sat
down but he then carried on
and i'm saying you know this is this is
sexist how many other how many of these
city guys sitting in here if you asked
then the guy next to me said who's on
the other side of the aisle said just
show him your ticket you know we just
start arguing just show him your ticket
and the woman in front of me
was doing this
i'm like don't calm me down
don't calm me down
and that's the problem we need you know
that's one of
when people say its job done it is not
job done
it really isn't job done
those are the rare instances where you
get to see it
but most of it you don't get to see
right most of that discrimination is
invisible
because it will be
small decisions compounding
against you because of discrimination
over decades and decades and decades
those are the instances where you can go
hmm that was clear prejudice because
that was just me
um i read that there was a bullying
culture and summers in the early
i heard that
for me okay yeah yeah yeah sorry i
thought you meant doing mine no no no no
no no but
that you um you kind of transformed that
because you didn't like
that yes yeah and again that was before
bullying was a thing
so we have a parent company called gold
group international and that person
worked
in that part of the business
um and
you know
and he wasn't the only person there were
others
and and bullying was um
entertainment
in those days there wasn't the open the
open um
culture that we have in businesses today
people wouldn't speak up
you know they they would assume they're
not going to be listened to or
um
but i you know
i knew it was going on and i thought
this is this is not this is not how i
want the business to be
so that was that was actually very very
early on
and you have a no sort of tolerance
approach to that
yeah i mean
i just don't i get to hear about you
know we're small enough that i get to
hear about most things and uh
that's not something i hear about and if
if we did we'd be all over it
i asked i unschooled my guest this
question you know you've built this
tremendous business it's hugely
successful and it's really as you said
it's more than just a financial success
because it's been a almost like a social
success it's been a societal success
because it's kind of led a
um perception shift it's dismantled the
stigma which i think as you've described
from the atmosphere you describe at
these early parties was like liberating
for people to be able to be open and um
speak freely about sexuality and
sex and which was to be at one point um
but a consequence of my point is the
consequence of business success is um
financial success
and what role has that played in your
in the in your life generally as it
relates to your fulfillment and
everything in between financial success
i mean obviously financial success is
something
you know that as a society i'm not
saying as a an individual but as a
society we
recognize as
you know one of the elements of success
and you know certainly
in my
younger time that was you know the more
sales the more bottom line all of these
things were
symbols of success that i recognized
and i
i started the female empowerment almost
from the day i started but didn't
realize it
so or i didn't i realized but i didn't
realize the relevance of it or the
importance of it or how
groundbreaking it was going to be you
know i wanted to create an environment
that was
for women i could see why i wanted to do
that
and
i wanted women to feel safe i wanted
them to be open
as time has evolved that passion for
doing that has evolved
along with
so many other things you know
that to me is what gives me the pleasure
more than
having nice clothes or or whatever you
know just the financial independence
that i've given
hundreds of thousands of women you know
during lockdown we had women earning
thirty thousand we were giving out
checks of thirty thousand pounds a month
obviously not to everybody but to our
top performers i mean it was like
who'd have thought we could be
we would be in a position to do that i
mean that's that was fantastic
sexual empowerment
for every woman became something that
was really important to me
in the last 10 years you know uh five
years
that's it that's broadened even further
to what we consider to be
every woman
you know our last campaign for example
which i was at a halloween campaign you
know we had trans we had an amputee
we had
slim girls we had curve girls we had
models we had customers
you know involved in this campaign
and that is what every woman is
and that
is something i really love
so
yeah money is money is nice because we
it makes us feel secure
um it's it
we're able to treat ourselves we're able
to do nice things um
you know i feel i've worked really
really hard and
you know i feel i'm
you know it's nice it's nice to have
nice things and do nice things and i
feel very privileged
but for me having that legacy which is
far more important to me that
for me female empowerment is is what i
stand for and i want to put my stake in
the ground and really own it
i was thinking though as you talked a
little bit about the pandemic um
much the reason why i started this
podcast was to highlight um
the more untold parts of
like ceos and professional people and
successful people's um journeys because
a lot of it's glamorized these days
entrepreneurship is seen as quite a
very aspirational thing to a younger
generation who can create you know
companies using their mobile phone now
but what was the um if when i say like
the worst day in business
like what's the day that comes to mind
for you
the hardest day the hardest day was when
the boris johnson announced that all
stores would have to close
retail would have to close
there was no mention
at that stage of
furlough schemes of rates holidays
um
you know there was
no
mention of
deals to be done with landlords
or what the future held
i i honestly
was in shock that day
yeah i can't imagine i can't imagine
that
because i don't work in that industry
just that
the prime minister announcing that you
have to close your business and not
offering any kind of hope
and i you know and
i went on i mentioned to you earlier i
went on the
on the on the retail calls
and
most companies
their their
their level of cash was low i mean
most companies based on what we were
offered at that time
was
you know you you didn't have more than
three months cash
so then they of course brought out the
sybil's loan
but
i think it was 80 guarantee
we needed that to be 100 guarantee
because there were so many
so many um
companies were refused credit
um because the banks were so scared so
that was you know you you'd thrown a
lifeline
and then you know we did this for about
there was about nine months of
you know constantly being thrown
lifelines that then didn't materialize
or
weren't applicable to you
in those um difficult moments
um we turned to our partners
in life you know they
you know many occasions bear the brunt
of that
chaos at home
how's your you know talk to me about
your home life and how you've met as a
ceo of a business that's gone through
things like that how you've managed to
maintain
a healthy relationship
um with your husband
um throughout all of this because i
think i need some advice
but you know it's interesting as he was
asking the question because
and i'm definitely not judging here i'm
just saying that my
i mean i i have a wonderful marriage i
have a lovely husband but when i was
going through health issues
you know
let's say you know he wasn't the best
he tried
but it's a very very difficult thing to
go through
and it spurns up a lot of emotions and i
think there were times that he
he was brilliant at times that he didn't
you know handle things as well
and i'm sure anybody listening would
know they've either been in this space
or
have been in my position can i ask
because i don't want to make that
mistake in my life what what what's um
what was missing in terms of i think
it's the emotional support okay i think
that's what men
struggle with
um perhaps in those situations
because um
i and i think he's so used to me being
strong that's what it is and he said
that to me at the time he is so used to
me being strong and resilient as you
said earlier and i was strong and
resilient but there was a vulnerability
about me because obviously i was having
having treatment that was debilitating
um
you know and i think he struggled with
that i think having you know at one
point you know i
i couldn't see i couldn't feel my feet
um
i was sleeping most of the time
obviously struggled with nausea
and i'd lost my hair so
that is
you can understand why anybody would
find that difficult
but in business
when i have business challenges
he
you know he's remarkably supportive
as many of you know i'm in the process
of making conscious switches in my life
and one of the sort of big switches
that's happening in my life at the
moment is my move towards living a more
sustainable life and that's where a
brand like my energy comes in who as
you'll know if you've listened to a
couple of episodes of this podcast are
one of my amazing sponsors my energy are
the uk's number one renewable energy
brand and they're on a mission to
increase the usage of green energy this
is one of their renewable energy
products if you're watching this on
youtube you'll be able to see this but
if not um beautiful little thing called
the zappy and i've spoken about this
device before but it's probably my
favorite product so far so i'm sharing
it again it's a smart ev electric
vehicle charger which simply allows you
to charge your electric vehicle from a
solar
or wind power source it's super easy to
install and it's super user friendly
saving you a ton of time and also saving
you a ton of money which is um a huge
bonus so if you are looking for a quick
fix for your electric vehicle or if you
want to become more sustainable then
head over to myenergy.com and check out
the zappy on their website to hear a lot
more
you talked as well at the very start of
this conversation about um
the passing of one of your children
um
another sort of inconceivable thing to
uh experience
you said at the start you've experienced
a lot of like misfortune
in your life
i mean that's right up there with things
that
everybody hopes will never happen to
them
are you are you comfortable to talk
about about that
yeah i'm okay
so you you have you had ivf
yes
tell me about that process i i've
learned you know i've it's it's it's
interesting because if it weren't for
this podcast
and some of the guests that i've sat
here with who've gone through the ivf
process and
that had the process failed for them
as a young man i would not have a clue
about any of that and you know what i
also wouldn't have a clue about
the struggles that um some women face
um to
become a parent
um so
whatever you can tell me about that
process and that experience i'd be
incredibly grateful for hmm
well
obviously it's not just women that
struggle it's men as well which i think
can be very difficult for some you know
for men i think they find that harder of
course
certainly when i went through the ivf
i mean it's 12 years over 12 years ago
now so
again it wasn't talked about like it is
now
and that
stigma makes it even more difficult and
you know makes everybody involved feel
you know
there's something wrong with you and it
can be so many different things you know
and it's i don't think it's just a given
that people just fall pregnant
and the journey i went on is i did three
ivfs
in this country
everything was if you fall pregnant if
you know if we can make an appointment
here if we can do that everything was an
if and felt a bit negative
and then i had to um one of the things i
had to do was
or we had to do as a couple we had to
see a counsellor i think i i don't know
if that's still part of the process but
you have to see a counsellor
and halfway through the counseling
session the counselor started having a
go at me
yeah she was saying you're very intense
i'm like well i'm just i'm just hanging
you know i'm listening to everything
you're saying and i'm interest
and she was
it felt like she was threatened by me
she felt uncomfortable with me
it was just a very negative approach and
then our fourth
so we we had a break for about two years
and then decided to go again and this
time we went to
san francisco
and everything was when
when you fall pregnant when this happens
oh really yeah we can make this
appointment call me anytime
nothing's a problem and
i just think we are
maybe things have changed and
you know this was
i was fortunate to use a private clinic
but there was still this
we're very cautious we're so cautious in
in britain but that adds to the anxiety
definitely
one might even go as far as saying that
reduces the chance of success absolutely
we talked about having an optimism bias
i'm totally i'm totally convinced of it
totally convinced and the disappointment
every time we failed
was overwhelming
you know there's this blame like who's
who's at fault here you know it is a
very difficult it's a very difficult
journey to go on
very difficult and the san francisco
procedure was successful yes
and i
i then found out i was pregnant with
twins
which was a shark
um i didn't want to know
what sex they were
and at my
first scan
he just spent a long time on one
on one of the babies
i didn't really notice it was my husband
that noticed something must be wrong
um
and afterwards the
radiographer said to us i'm sorry but
one of the
one of the fetuses is uh
has a
he used words like an abnormal brain um
a morbid outcome
and i think i can still pronounce the
condition but it the condition
that alfie had was a lobar holland press
and kephaly
which
is basically
he just has enough brain to live
and um
to hear that
well in fact i didn't think he was going
to make the pregnancy they said he he i
was told he wouldn't make 19 weeks
but
um
of course
he did he he went through to birth and
that was very difficult for me because i
had
grieved for him when he was in the womb
so it was a big shock to me when he was
born
and i found bonding with him difficult
at first
i found
um
diffic i found it difficult
going to the hospital
um i i was in hospital for a week
um before i was able to go home um i'd
had a cesarean it was a two-hour it was
a two-hour journey
and i obviously would take scarlet with
me
um
but that was a very difficult time a
very difficult time for me
and he was in hospital
for quite some time
and then eventually
we had the confidence to move him out of
a
out of the hospital and into a fantastic
home called the children's trust in
tadworth
and then i think that was when i was
able to start to build a relationship
with him
but nothing prepares you for that
nothing prepares you for that
yeah i mean yeah it's just unthinkable
and you know
as hard as this is to hear
you know he was born in pain and i hear
your son
born crying in pain not as a any other
you know that was
that was just the worst thing on earth
that the impact that has on
a relationship as well
a marriage
oh god it's just so many there's so many
feelings right you know they say
you know it it's ironic that the
going through the ivf
probably
you know caused arguments and drove us
apart
but
when we had our son and he was you know
obviously
in hospital and then at the children's
trust and with this devastating illness
um
it pulled us together and my husband i
you know was absolutely amazing and i
mean to have a strong person by your
side in the worst situation you could
ever have
but on the you know we did
manage to
scarlett was able to spend lots of time
with him we were able to take
lots of lovely video footage of him
he
was looked after so well there and all
of the sensory
treatment they they give is amazing and
you know now um
we have all of of alfie's memories and
you know i've kept a pirate's box for
him and um
you know he's very much part of
scarlet's life even though he's not here
thank you for your honesty though um i
think it's just tremendously uh valuable
and eye-opening
and it's a window that into a
a set of life events that few um
few are um misfortune enough to
experience but um i'm glad i'm just very
uh glad that you
find the confidence to
give us that because yeah
these are things that you know
people are naive to
unless they go through them and i think
a lot of the things that you've talked
about today
um people are naive too unless they go
through them
um so sharing it okay like for me is
never gonna make me understand fully
but i think it gives me a ton of empathy
towards
um
the people that go through those
situations so thank you for that um
something else you mentioned at the
start of this conversation was about a
nanny and i i wrote that down because it
was a slightly obscure thing to hear
but i wanted to come back to it just
before we we conclude which was that you
were poisoned by an annie
i've been very unlucky haven't i oh yeah
yeah um i mean this was bizarre this was
bizarre this is like a movie i had this
nanny uh it was when alfie was
uh obviously in the home so i needed all
the help i could get and um
i trusted her implicitly with my
daughter
and
i had a really good relationship with
her i liked her she was a lovely girl
and you know very reliable etc
i also had
a lady that used to sort of pop in with
and do odd jobs and
while i was going through that period
without fee she would also prepare our
meals so all i had to do
uh
before hallow fresh and gusto it's what
i had to do to um
you know she'd just make it easier for
me and
what i didn't know
was that she and the nanny didn't get on
and
the nanny instead of coming to me and
saying look
i've got a problem here can we talk
about it
she thought the best
tactic would be to get the cook the sack
so
she thought i know i'll start off
by putting uh
copious amounts of sugar in in in the
food after she's prepared it
so i came home from work and i'm sat
there and
cooked dinner everything seems fine
and we had fish and when we sat down to
eat the fish the sauce tasted like
custard
um
but you know the first time it happens
you think maybe she acts i don't know
maybe she's just used the wrong pot yeah
and the second time a few weeks later
same thing happened again this time
it was salt
and i thought
there's something wrong here
um
and
i want i obviously needed to talk to the
to the lady that was doing the food
so that's what i'd arranged to do
but before i had chance to speak to her
um
the nanny was taking my daughter to blue
water and i'd left my lunch at home
and so i called her i said you wouldn't
drop it in for me would you she said
yeah no problem i'll do it on the way
so she came over
unbeknown to me on the way pulled over
poured
um
[Music]
screen wash into my soup
sealed it all back up again then went to
the petrol station sorted herself out
petrol for the car she's got my daughter
in the back
brings it to my office
gets in the lift brings it up gives it
to me as
say thanks ali taking it from her
then she's gone off to blue water with
scarlet
so i didn't know straight away because
it wasn't until i'd come to i came to
eat it
at um
lunch time
luckily
i took
quite a large mouthful and the reason i
say that is because i don't think i
would have tasted it otherwise
um and i spat it out because immediately
it tasted of chemical
because screenwash can kill you
and um
yeah we i then went into
meltdown because obviously she got my
daughter with her
did you know straight away but she'd
done that
i
yes i i it was just instinct my instinct
was
she it was her but i needed to talk to
the cook first
but this all happened too quickly
i thought if i ring the police issue of
sound mind would you know would that
make things worse
so i just waited for her to to because
she was due to come back anyway and drop
scarlet off with me
and
um yeah when she did um i took scarlett
and um
my hr
um gary at the time and uh someone else
my sister actually i think it was
um confronted her
and what did she admitted you joke
first of all she denied it but went
bright red
and then
they said look
if you tell us the truth we won't need
to get the police involved so she just
blurted it out she said okay i did it i
don't i don't like the cook
i don't like the cook
and uh
of course i then felt i could do nothing
but call the police because
this is a woman that
is going to even when she leaves even
when she leaves me she's going to get
another job doing this
where she could do something like this
to another family
and and so
she was charged
it went to court she appeared on
good morning britain first thing in the
morning
and was at court in the afternoon
which didn't go down with the judge eith
well with the judges you can imagine
um you know trying to get public
sympathy and and
sorry public sympathy
yeah i think
you know
these people don't always
see their own wrongs do they they they
it's never their fault
who's what was it and have you
um
i think she just she was just trying to
put herself across in a in a positive
way
um
you know
she wasn't trying to harm me but
nevertheless she was in a trusted
position
and
you can imagine that the sort of trauma
i felt for those few hours
and actually afterwards because
you know you then are questioning
whether you can ever trust anybody again
um
i'm
i just
you know it's something else that makes
you feel vulnerable
um she you know she kept messaging me
trying to get the
the court case cancelled and of course
once it goes through that process it
can't anyway
she was uh found guilty she was
sentenced to
um a year in prison
and she served three months [ __ ] you
know
that is awful
do you know me like potentially killing
somebody and um poisoning someone's food
you get three months in prison
and then when she came out of prison
i then
had to take out an injunction on her
because i found out that she
was trying to write a book about that
time
i mean you know how much more disgusting
can it get
what a ride
[Laughter]
it's been very colorful
what do you like inclusive
life lessons
when you reflect on your own journey in
business in life what are some of the
like you know the things you'd say to
your daughter if you were trying to
advise her on
the potential rollercoaster that life
can be as it has been for you
i mean
i tried i'm somebody who tries to have
few regrets because i don't think
there's any great benefit to that but
there are things i definitely would have
done differently
um i think you know i do have courage
but you can never have enough of it
and
in certain situations i always find
myself the first one to
be daring
i suppose is the word i'm looking for
um
i think that's a good thing i could
think that's a good thing in life i
think being engaging is a good quality
i'd want my daughter to have
which is why i've always wanted her to
be as confident as possible
to always believe that you not only can
you be anything you want to be but you
don't have to follow the norm and
actually it's good to be different
my business pieces would be slightly
different actually because i
you know i think
the things i wish i'd done more of are
networking
um and i i
told you about the story about going to
san diego and i guess that's where i was
going with that because in america
networking is something that people do
all the time
and
in this country at the time i started
out it was nowhere near what it is today
and i think particularly for women
women you know i'm you know my husband
is a brilliant networker i mean
you know
wherever he does it he'll do anywhere
and you know
i know when he says oh i was playing
golf again actually
you know he's um
he's just natural at it it's it's part
of who he is
but
i think you know women it's a thing
where you think i haven't got time for
that i've got to really focus on this
job or i've got to finish this deadline
or
but i have realized as i've got older
you know every time you walk in a room
and meet a room full of strangers
there's an opportunity there
you know that could possibly change your
life
and actually
you were telling me something similar
earlier
when you were talking about the
apprentice oh right yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah
so
you know
i've got to
basically we were talking about the
apprentice before we started recording
and um uh chuckling you were on the the
apprentice yeah um
and i was saying that i basically got
through off the apprentice the junior
apprentice when i was 14 years old as
some of you might know
um but in the queue i met a family the
alawalia family
um it was actually the earth the son of
the alawalia billionaire i believe he's
a billionaire now was in the queue with
me got chatting tim j alawalia and
although i got kicked off the show and
therefore didn't get the 25 grand that i
would have got 14 years old to start my
business he ended up investing multiples
more than that in my business and that
was just someone that i met in the queue
and had great conversation with because
we were auditioning together for seven
hours so
um and i think that's brilliant a
brilliant example
yeah i completely agree yeah so um
and the people piece that i said to you
earlier i wished
i had recognized the importance of you
know for me
you know people are the success of your
business and
i wished i'd recognized that earlier
a
men to that
that's this that's the single number one
thing that i wish i'd recognized earlier
i thought it was about me
because i was naive and yeah and
probably a bit i don't know arrogant i
thought my business success was about my
ability
but it was all about the people that i
pulled together and the culture i bound
them with
so
i had an idea last week which we wanted
to try historically we get our guests
just to sign the book
but um what i would like you to do
instead of that as well as signing the
book is just to write a question
and whoever sits in this seat next and
it could be anybody right could be
someone at the very very top of
business the very top of politics the
very top of sports
um could be anybody i'm gonna ask them
to i'm gonna ask them that question
we're not gonna we're not gonna read it
out right now but next week's episode i
will post them that question so whatever
question you wanna write in this book
feel free okay there's gonna be a secret
until next week's episode okay
thank you so much um thank you you know
you're just remarkable it's quite
staggering that
you've both
gone through so much adversity as you've
described and
misfortune as you've you've called it
and um yeah you are the person you are
today and there's such a huge amount of
optimism which shines through when you
speak about these incidents and even you
know you're talking about some of some
incidents that are just unthinkable for
one person to go through in their life
just one of those incidents yeah you
always
in it with a butt and that was always
the silver lining and i think to have
that
attitude where you can always see the
silver lining or the the lesson or the
value in adversity is a remarkable thing
that um
i think
you know will will create as we
described with the negativity bias that
you saw in the ivf system in the uk can
actually dictate the outcome in our
lives yeah and the last two years has
been you know the greatest need for an
optimism bias i think we've all
experienced so thank you you've inspired
me tremendously i read about your story
before you came here today and i was
just blown away but i was blown away by
your success as well as a businesswoman
because coming into a company at 19 and
becoming the ceo and leading it as you
have and changing the business and then
leading this incredible charge against
uh
you know
a male stigma um but more broadly a
social stigma around sex sexualization
and sex and
and um
and
i guess equality um
is just a remarkable remarkable thing
you know and this is the reason why i
started this podcast was to get to meet
people like you that would inspire me
and i just happened to record it so
other people could listen so thank you
well it's been a real joy i i i have
really enjoyed it
um
and i really look forward to hearing it
and seeing it yeah
thank you so much honestly amazing yeah
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]